well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with andrew pierce
consultant editor of the daily mail and
kevin mcguire associate editor of the
daily mirror with us from now until just
before midnight welcome to both of you
lots to discuss
let's take a look shall we penny's
dropped is the metro's headline as
former favorite penny mordon lost out on
the final two by eight votes
the eye reports that liz trust is now
the new favorite to become prime
minister with the foreign secretary
ahead in polls of party members
same lead for the front of the financial
times as the challengers both argue they
are best placed to beat labour
in the daily mail this trust vows to
hold an emergency tax cut budget and
stand up to those who talk down our
country history and values
advantage trusts in the race to bpm is
the telegraph's headline as mr sunak
writes in the paper that he respects his
opponent and recognizes the need for tax
cuts
but the times leads on suggestions from
the chancellor or the former chancellor
that the conservatives will lose power
unless he is elected the guardian says
the tory party is braced for a blue and
blue dog fight as the six weeks of
hustings kick off
farewell boris is the daily expresses
headline after he featured in what is
expected to be his last prime minister's
questions
and the start reports one netflix boss
predicting mainstream tv will be dead in
a decade with the headline it's good
night from me and good night from him
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so
let us bring in andrew pierce consultant
editor of the mail kevin mcguire
associate editor of the mirror uh with
the news that we know who might be the
next prime minister uh what do you make
of the choice andrew
um i thought at the beginning that
morden had the momentum but it stalled
very badly uh and i wasn't surprised at
all that the last two are sunak and
truss
the problem for penny morgan was she'd
not had much scrutiny because she'd not
been in the cabinet for the last three
years when she was subjected to intense
scrutiny i think part of her record
disintegrated really and i think she
would have had quite a difficult six
weeks as in the last two so i think it's
probably the
best result
they are the two most senior tories in
the sense liz trusses foreign secretary
she's the longest serving cabinet
minister now because michael gove is out
of the cabinet uh trust uh sorry sunak
was the chance of the it's checker but
they are the big beasts uh and uh and i
think it would be an interesting contest
and i would imagine
uh trust will win for a couple of
reasons uh tory members do not like
disloyalty and they will not like the
way sunak knifed boris in the end and
also they will be deeply unhappy as lots
of people who vote toriyar
subjected the country to the highest tax
burden for 70 years and i have to say
i think it's staggering that he's
writing in the telegraph tonight that
we've got to have tax cuts when his
whole pitch in the leadership election
until now was we can't afford tax cuts
he's panicking because he realizes liz
trusts his uh uh agenda of tax cuts and
an emergency tax cutting budget is going
to win over tory members yeah and just
quickly and i'm not going to dwell on
this because you're not here to defend
your paper you know morden's campaign
disintegrated you know partly it is
suggested by the coverage in the daily
mail
well actually uh um uh uh anna i wrote
one of the big pieces about um eddie
morton's campaign and there is no doubt
in my view she was looking two ways on
um the issue of trans issues uh there
was uh suggestions but which were borne
out uh subsequently by cabinet ministers
in public interviews that she was not
always uh
at the job uh lord frost had suggested
that in an interview we reported that in
good faith uh i reported that when she
was defense secretary there was some
suggestion that the reason she was
removed after 89 days was not because
she voted for jeremy hunt in the
leadership contest in 2019 but boris had
been told by the generals the up the top
brass she wasn't really up to it and
there were serious question marks about
whether penny morgan had the
intellectual rigor to do the job and i
think we were right to report that in
the mail and other papers did too
so um kevin let's have a look at the
coverage in the papers then uh the daily
telegraph advantage trusts in the race
to be the pm um the suggestion is that
she plays better amongst uh you know the
current electorate which is the tory
members but not necessarily represented
by the tory people who vote tori um the
times
with the big pitch of rishi sunak pick
me or lose power so his message will be
i'm more likely to win the next general
election the question is which battle
will win out
no absolutely and that's the crucial the
crucial battle it's winning the next
election that's what conservative mps
were thinking about i think that's what
conservative members will be looking at
and it is
unusual i think that the telegraph is
right that she has uh a narrow advantage
to start because so many polls have
shown she will win among that sect that
is the tory party membership in the
country was 160 thousand two hundred
thousand top whack that's less than 0.3
percent of the country of 67 million
will decide who the next prime minister
is without a general uh election that's
the system that's how it works i'm not
sure how that is how it should
work and
uh
you're right the mail and the mail on
sunday in particular really went for
penny more than other papers did as
andrew says some of the scrutiny i
thought was fair some of it i thought
wasn't wasn't fair i'm not sure her
campaign disintegrated she got 105 votes
which was pretty good she was only eight
behind liz trust all it needed was four
tory mps to
to change signs but watching penny more
than the the attack i couldn't quite
believe and i watched it was on sky news
it was a beth rigby speaking to anne
marie trevelyan who was penny morden's
boss uh to trade still is her boss at
trade saying she wasn't really doing the
job i thought it was absolutely
incredible i can't recall a minister
attacking another serving minister a
junior serving minister
in that way but rishi sunak uh he
concedes that he's starting from behind
that he's uh second he's got a power
forward i'm not sure it's in the back
for trust as as much as it's kind of
being assumed with uh the bookies we've
seen surveys and polls all over the
place so far and i think minds will be
be focused
however i dis uh disagree politically
with sunak and trust you're going to say
that um sunak always strikes me as an
adult grown up while trust looks a
frightened rabbit watching her in the
the last debate on itv
uh she she clearly was struggling and
she could be found out in the
head-to-head debates when they start to
be on tv as you know sky will do one bbc
will do one i'm sure the channels will
and then you have those 12 regional
hostings around
around the country she's going to have a
lot of questions to answer just as soon
as i will
yes and uh that you know the telegraph
says mr sunax allies believe an
increased number of media appearances
and public events will win over support
presumably therefore commerce to the
detriment of liz truss and the and the
tax cuts part of it he does say
ultimately tax cuts are ultimately
needed for growth his message to liz
trust has always been that actually tax
tax cuts are inflationary and that's the
thing we really need to control right
now um but moving on to the guardian
then blue on blue dog fight as soon i
can trust face off you know will we see
more of this
um you know skull duggary you know the
bad words or or will it clean up now do
you think andrew
i think it will clean up because i think
the big mistake was i couldn't believe
they agreed to it five of them on a
platform in the champ with channel 4
with an audience which was always going
to be hostile frankly to the tory party
a channel 4 audience uh it was madness i
couldn't believe they did it uh
one-on-one is fine it's a proper
grown-up debate uh and and and the itv
debate um i i again i couldn't believe
it i thought julie etching was very good
but again it got very personal and
abusive and it was giving gifts to
labour by the dozen uh talking of
socialism and
too high taxes i mean labour are going
to bottle that uh some of those
broadcasts and use them in party
political broadcast from now until the
general election so they were right to
cook paul paul the plug in my view but i
think the debate between uh the former
chancellor and the foreign secretary
would be much more civilized much more
grown up and could be very illuminating
and there is no doubt that liz trust is
wooden she's a very wooden performer i
think she needs to uh raise her game in
that respect i talked to her people
before and said you know she does a very
very possible impersonation of a dalek
and she needs to change that
mrs thatcher remember though when she
first got in 1979 she was very shrill
her hair was terrible her teeth were
terrible her clothes were terrible and
she she just got better and she grew
into the job and was uh fantastic in my
view in the end so just can grow and
learn in the in the job but she's only
got six weeks in which to show that
she's the polished performer because
rishi is an incredibly polished
performer but i wonder if some people
might think just a bit too slick those
slick videos just all a bit too
polished for some people not enough
rough edges no that's interesting i mean
to be fair liz truss
as you know has has had a chance to grow
into the job she's had a number of high
profile ministerial roles already hasn't
she i just want to just just finish this
section on boris johnson uh you might
say here he ended pmq's in in his usual
ebullient style um you know has to love
easter baby see you later he refrained
from i'll be back but was that the hint
do you think kevin
yeah you know liz truss has uh has grown
at the job hopefully now as foreign
secretary she won't confuse the black
and the baltic seas anymore when they
are 700 miles apart maybe she goes to
bed with an atlas and finds out where
the the world is i think it's a an odd
choice for the express it has been the
cheerleader to the bitter end of boris
johnson but the story's moved on to who
to be the next prime minister is it
going to be sunak or is he going to be
trus
and farewell the boris it's almost a
black border there around on the express
as they as they were
weep and you know that part part in
shock that rishi was quite clear i don't
think there's any hidden i'll be back uh
he shouldn't be quite fun terminator i
think true line is the film that would
be more appropriate for boris johnson
given his record of fibbing all the way
he'll he'll hang on although there are
uh there are rumors he might go for the
edit ship of the uh
evening standard which of course you
could get a lot of money and uh oh god
who's owns that let's think about oh i
know it's lord lebanon moscow isn't it
who's who's dad the former kgb spy he
met in italy
see
but we will see as you say anyway he has
andrew shaking his head
all of that he's not going to be at it
he's not going to do the evening
standing because it's only about four
pages maybe taking five minutes to edit
it
okay that would be that would prove that
would prove it that would be too easy
even for boris he's not exactly fame for
his appetite for hard work
it could give him a lot of time to do
other things he's got to basically steam
off all that gold wallpaper now in
number 10 because he paid for it in the
end
he could always get somebody
retrospectively to uh bung in the cash
maybe that's how they'll judge who uh
who's the next pm whether they'll live
with the wallpaper or not anyway we'll
see shall we lots more walls
including the telegraph europeans are
urged to turn off their lights amid
fears that president putin will cut off
gas supplies we'll talk about that next
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview uh with me once again
andrew pearce consultant editor of the
daily mail and kevin mcguire associate
editor of the daily mirror welcome back
to both of you so kevin um we head to
the telegraph story that europeans have
been urged to turn off their lights turn
off their aircon you know reduce energy
use and it's all about gas and russia
it is uh fifteen percent reduction is
the target uh ursa vondelin the european
commission president saying look russia
is blackmailing european countries uh
powerhouses such as germany depends so
heavily on russian fuel and the ukraine
war in many ways is not in the headlines
anymore you very rarely read it on
the front pages but you can see the
reluctance of some countries to impose
tougher sanctions precisely because they
are dependent and russia could turn off
the taps and it would lose uh income
which is why it doesn't do it of course
but it would plunge those economies into
a deep depression and it it is serious
it's
we're paying a price for being dependent
on carbon fuels from putin for so many
uh so many years yeah we just got one
minute left andrew actually um and it
looks like the ft uh has been looking
into lord alan sugar
under pressure to clarify his tax status
in the uk
yeah they've got a good story here it's
obviously a scoop they've revealed that
he's taking leave of absence from the
house of lords quite a lot of peers do
that but they suggest the tax
arrangement he's in suggests that he is
he about to
go abroad and possibly become a tax
exile or um go offshore all of this is
fascinating not least because of course
he still presents that tv show that i've
never watched actually the apprentice
that would be very hard to carry on i
would have thought uh for a household
named show like that if he's um
domiciling himself overseas for tax
purposes to save money he's a very very
rich man
and therefore
if this story is correct it suggests
he's going to go elsewhere to limit his
taxing tax in fact and we need every
penny we get in this country in the tax
coffers thank you very much lord sugar
lord sugar spokes person saying we are
instructed to tell you that lord sugar
is a uk taxpayer and will remain so
please do not ask any further questions
as they will not be answered so there we
are we've run out of time i do apologize